Professor Shelly Kagan:
Last time we made the turn from
metaphysics to value theory.
We started asking about what it
is about death that makes it
bad.
The first aspect of the badness
of death that we talked about
was the fact that when somebody
dies, that's hard on the rest of
us.
We're left behind having to
cope with the loss of this
person that we love.
Nonetheless,
it seems likely that if we want
to get clear about the central
badness of death,
it can't be a matter of the
loss for those who remain
behind, but rather the loss,
the badness of death,
for the person who dies.
That, at any rate,
is what I want to focus on from
here on out.
What exactly is it about my
death, or the fact that I'm
going to die,
that makes that bad for me?
Now, I want to get clear about
precisely what it is we want to
focus in on here.
Now, one thing that could be
bad, obviously,
is the process of dying could
be a painful one.
It might be,
for example,
that I get ripped to pieces by
Bengali tigers.
And if so, then the actual
process of dying would be
horrible.
It would be painful.
And clearly it makes sense to
talk about the process of dying
as something that could
potentially be bad for me.
Although similarly,
I might die in my sleep,
in which case the process of
dying would not be bad for me.
At any rate,
I take it that most of us,
although we might have some
passing concern about the
possibility that our process of
dying might be a painful one,
that's not, again,
the central thing we're
concerned about when we face the
fact that we're going to die.
It's also true,
of course, that many of us
find--;here, right now,
while we're not actually
dying--the prospect of
dying to be unpleasant.
So, one of the things that's
bad about my death for me is
that right now I've got some
unhappy thoughts as I anticipate
the fact that I'm going to die.
But again, that can't be the
central thing that's bad about
death, because the prospect of
my death--it makes sense for
that to be a painful one or an
unpleasant one,
only given the further claim
that death itself is bad for me.
Having fear or anxiety or
concern or regret or anguish or
whatever it is that maybe I have
now about the fact that I'm
going to die,
piggybacks on the logically
prior thought that death itself
is bad for me.
If it didn't piggyback in that
way, it wouldn't make any sense
to have fear or anxiety or dread
or anguish or whatever it is
that I may have now.
I mean, suppose I said to you,
"Tomorrow something's going to
happen to you and that thing is
going to be simply fantastic,
absolutely incredible,
absolutely wonderful."
And you said,
"Well, I believe you and I have
to tell you, I'm just filled
with dread and foreboding in
thinking about it."
That wouldn't make any sense at
all.
It makes sense to be filled
with dread or foreboding or what
have you only if the thing
you're looking forward to,
anticipating,
is itself bad.
Maybe, for example,
it makes sense to dread going
to the dentist,
if you believe that being at
the dentist is a painful,
unpleasant experience.
But if being at the dentist
isn't itself unpleasant,
it doesn't make sense to dread
it in anticipation.
So again, if we're thinking
about the central badness of
death, it seems to me that we've
got to focus on my being
dead.
What is it about my
being dead that's bad for
me?
Now, if we pose that question,
it seems as though the answer
should be simple and
straightforward.
When I'm dead, I won't exist.
Now previously,
in the first part of the class,
we spent some time saying that,
look, on certain views,
there'll be a period of time in
which you might be dead,
but your body might still be
alive.
Or you might be dead,
but even though your body still
exists, it's not alive,
but you exist as a corpse.
Put all that aside.
Go to the period beyond any of
that murky stuff in the
short-term and just,
for simplicity,
let's suppose with the
physicalists that once I die,
I cease to exist.
All right.
So, don't we have the answer to
what's bad about death right
there?
When I'm dead, I won't exist.
Isn't that the straightforward
explanation about why death is
bad?
Now, what I want to say,
in effect, is this.
I do think the fact that I
won't exist does provide the key
to getting clear about how and
why death is bad.
But I don't think it's quite
straightforward.
I think, as we'll see,
it actually takes some work to
spell out exactly how death,
how nonexistence,
could be bad for me.
And even having done that,
there'll be some puzzles that
remain that we'll be turning to
in a little while.
So, the basic idea seems to be
straightforward enough.
When I'm dead, I won't exist.
Isn't it clear that
nonexistence is bad for me?
Well, immediately you get an
objection.
You say, how could
nonexistence be bad for me?
After all, the whole point of
nonexistence is you don't exist.
How could anything be bad for
you when you don't exist?
Isn't there a kind of logical
requirement that for something
to be bad for you,
you've got to be around to
receive that bad thing?
A headache, for example,
can be bad for you.
But of course,
you exist during the headache.
Headaches couldn't be bad for
people who don't exist.
They can't experience or have
or receive headaches.
How could anything be
bad for you when you don't
exist?
And in particular,
then, how could nonexistence be
bad for you when you don't
exist?
So it's not,
as I say, altogether
straightforward to see how the
answer "Death is bad for me,
because when I'm dead I don't
exist," how that answers
the problem, as opposed to
simply focusing our attention on
the problem.
How can nonexistence be bad for
me?
The answer to this objection,
I think, is to be found in
drawing a distinction between
two different ways in which
something can be bad for me.
On the one hand,
something can be bad for me,
we might say,
in an absolute,
robust, intrinsic sense.
Take a headache,
again, or some other kind of
pain--stubbing your toe or
getting stabbed or whatever it
is, being tortured.
Pain is intrinsically
bad.
It's bad in its own right.
It's something we want to avoid
for its own sake.
And those--;Normally,
things that are bad for you are
bad intrinsically.
They're bad by virtue of their
very nature.
There's something about the way
they are that you don't want
those that are bad in their own
right.
But there's another way of
something being bad for you that
it's easy to overlook.
Something can be bad
comparatively.
Something could be bad because
of what you're not getting while
you get this bad thing.
It could be what the economists
call bad by virtue of "the
opportunity costs."
It's not that it's
intrinsically bad;
it's bad because while you're
doing this, you're not getting
something better.
How could that be?
Let's have a simple example.
Suppose that I stay home and
watch something on TV--Deal
or No Deal.
I watch this on TV and I have a
good enough time.
How could that be bad for me?
Well, in terms of the first
notion of bad,
something being intrinsically
bad, it's not bad.
It's a pleasant enough way to
spend a half an hour,
or however long the show is on.
On the other hand,
suppose what I could be doing
instead of watching a half an
hour of television is being at a
really great party.
Then we might say,
the fact that I'm stuck home
watching television is bad for
me in this comparative
sense.
It's not that it's,
in itself, an unpleasant way to
spend some time;
it's just that there's a better
way to spend time that I could
be doing, in principle at least.
If only I'd gone.
If only I'd been invited.
If only I remembered,
what have you.
And because I'm foregoing that
better good, there's something
bad, comparatively speaking,
about the fact that I'm stuck
at home watching TV.
There's a lack of the better
good.
A lack is not
intrinsically bad,
but it's still a kind of bad in
this second sense.
To be lacking a good is,
itself, bad for me.
Similarly, suppose I hold out
two envelopes and I say,
"Pick one."
And you open up the first one,
you pick the first one,
and you open it up and you say,
"Hey look, ten bucks!
Isn't that good for me?"
Well, of course,
ten bucks is intrinsically
good.
Anyway, well,
it's not intrinsically good,
it's only good as a means to
buy something.
But it's sort of good.
It's worth having for its own
right, because of what it can
get you.
But if unbeknownst to you,
the other envelope had $1,000
in it, then we can say,
"Look, it's bad for you that
you picked the first envelope."
Bad in what sense?
Because you would have been
better off, had you picked the
second envelope.
You would have been having more
good, or a greater amount of
good.
Well, nonexistence can't be bad
for me in our first sense.
It can't be that nonexistence
is intrinsically bad,
worth avoiding for its own
sake.
That would only make sense if
nonexistence was somehow,
for example,
painful.
But when you don't exist,
you have no painful
experiences.
There's nothing about
nonexistence in and of itself
that makes us want to avoid it.
Nonexistence is only bad for me
in this comparative sense,
because of the lack.
When I don't exist,
I'm lacking stuff.
What am I lacking?
Well, of course,
what I'm lacking is life
and more particularly still,
the good things that
life can give me.
So, nonexistence is bad by
virtue of the opportunity costs
that are involved.
Famously, W.C.
Fields on his tombstone says,
"Personally,
I'd rather be in Philadelphia."
What's bad about being dead is
you don't get to experience and
enjoy any longer the various
good things that life would
offer us.
So nonexistence does point to
the key aspect about death.
Why is death bad?
Because when I'm dead I don't
exist.
But if we ask,
why is and how can it be the
case that nonexistence is bad?
the answer is,
because of the lack of the good
things in life.
Because when I don't exist,
I am not getting the things
that I could have otherwise
gotten, if only I were still
alive.
Death is bad because it
deprives me of the good things
in life.
This account is nowadays known
as the deprivation
account of the evil or badness
of death, for obvious reasons,
right?
The key thought is,
the central bad about death,
about nonexistence,
is that it deprives you
of the goods of life you might
otherwise be getting.
That's the deprivation account.
And it seems to me that the
deprivation account basically
has it right.
Eventually, I'll go on to argue
that there are other aspects of
death that may also contribute
to its badness,
aspects above and beyond the
one that gets focused on by the
deprivation account.
But still, it seems to me the
deprivation account points us
correctly to the central thing
about death that's bad.
What's most importantly bad
about the fact that I'll be dead
is the fact that when I'm dead,
I won't be getting the good
things in life.
I'll be deprived of them.
That's the badness of death
according to the deprivation
account.
Now, if we accept the
deprivation account,
if we try to accept the
we face some further
philosophical puzzles.
Puzzles that many people have
thought are sufficiently
overwhelming that we,
despite the initial
plausibility of the deprivation
account, have to give it up.
First objection is this.
Look, if something is true--a
quite general point,
it seems, about metaphysics--if
something is true,
there's got to be a time
when it's true.
If I make some claim about a
fact, there's got to be a time
when that fact is true.
Here's a fact.
Shelly's lecturing to you now
about the badness of death.
When is that fact true?
When was that fact true?
Well, right now.
Here's another fact.
Shelly once lectured to you
about the nature of personal
identity.
When was that fact true?
Well, we can point to a period
of perhaps a week or two last
month when I was lecturing to
you about personal identity.
Things that are facts can be
dated.
All right.
That seems right.
But if it is right,
then immediately we've got a
puzzle.
How could death be bad for me?
If death was bad for me,
that would be a fact.
If my death is bad for me,
that would be a fact and we'd
ask, well, when is that fact
true?
We might say,
well, it's not true now.
Death isn't bad for me now.
I'm not dead now.
Maybe death is bad for me when
I'm dead?
But that seems very hard to
believe.
I mean, when I'm dead,
I don't exist,
right?
How could anything be bad for
me then?
Surely you've got to exist.
So, there's a puzzle about
dating the badness of death.
Now, it may be that this puzzle
about time and the date of the
badness of death is what
Epicurus had in mind.
There's a passage that I'm
going to read to you in a moment
from Epicurus.
This passage has puzzled
people, it has puzzled
philosophers ever since.
Epicurus seems to be putting
his finger on something puzzling
about death, though it's
difficult to pin down exactly
what it is that's bugging him.
So we're going to try an
interpretation or two.
But first, here's the passage
from Epicurus.
"So death, the most terrifying
of ills, is nothing to us,
since so long as we exist,
death is not with us;
but when death comes,
then we do not exist.
It does not then concern either
the living or the dead,
since for the former it is not,
and the latter are no more."
You see, it's not altogether
clear what Epicurus is bothered
by there, but one possible
interpretation is this puzzle
about the timing of the badness
of death.
Death can't be bad for me now,
because I'm alive.
Death can't be bad for me when
I'm dead.
I am no more;
then how can things be bad for
me then?
But if death has no time at
which it's bad for me,
and if anything that's true,
any fact has to have a time
when it's true,
then the purported fact that
death is bad for me can't really
be a fact.
All right.
How could we respond to this
objection?
Well, one way of course is to
accept the objection and say,
"You're right.
Death isn't really bad for me."
And some philosophers have
indeed accepted that very
conclusion, maybe Epicurus.
Most of us want to say, "No, no.
Death is bad for me."
So we need a better answer to
the, "Oh yeah?
When is it bad for you?"
objection.
Two possible responses.
One possible response would be
to grab the bull by the horns
and say, "Death is bad for me.
Facts do have to be dated.
Let me tell you when it's bad
for me."
The other possible response is
to grab, as it were,
the other horn and say,
"You know,
death is bad for me and I agree
that I can't date it,
but you're wrong to assume that
all facts have to be datable.
There are some things that are
true that we can't put a date
on."
Let's start with the second.
Could there be some things that
are true that we can't put a
date on?
Well, here's one I think, maybe.
Suppose that on Monday I shoot
John.
I wound him with the bullet
that comes out of my gun.
But it's not a wound directly
into his heart.
He simply starts bleeding.
And he bleeds slowly.
So he doesn't die on Monday.
He's wounded and he's dying,
but he doesn't die on Monday.
On Tuesday, let's suppose that
I have a heart attack and I die.
John's still around--bleeding,
but still around.
On Wednesday,
the loss of blood finally
overtakes him and John dies.
All right?
So, I shoot him on Monday,
I die on Tuesday,
John dies on Wednesday.
Now, I killed John.
I take it we're all in
agreement about that.
If I hadn't shot him,
he wouldn't be dead.
I killed him.
When did I kill him?
Did I kill him on Monday,
the day I shot him?
That doesn't seem right.
He's not dead on Monday.
How could I kill him on Monday?
Oh, he died on Wednesday.
Did I kill him on Wednesday?
Well, how could that be?
I don't even exist on Wednesday.
I died myself on Tuesday.
How can I kill him after I'm
dead?
So I didn't kill him on Monday,
didn't kill him--rather on
Wednesday.
I didn't kill him on Monday,
didn't kill him on Wednesday
when he dies.
When did I kill him?
Well, maybe the answer is
there's no particular time at
all when I killed him.
But for all that,
it's true that I killed him.
What makes it true that I
killed him?
killed him is that on Monday I
shot him and on Wednesday,
he died from the wound.
That's what makes it true.
But when did I kill him?
Maybe we can't date that.
Suppose we can't.
If we can't,
then there are facts that you
can't date, like the fact that I
killed John.
If there are facts that you
can't date, maybe here's another
one.
My death is bad for me.
When is that true?
Can't date it,
but for all that,
maybe it's true.
So maybe we shouldn't accept
the assumption of the argument
that all facts can be dated.
Of course, the thought that all
facts can be dated is a very
powerful one,
and no doubt,
many of you are going to go
home and start trying to come up
with an adequate answer to the
question,
when exactly did Shelly kill
John?
And come up with an answer,
maybe, that you can even
accept.
At any rate,
maybe we should accept the
thought that all facts can be
dated.
In which case,
if we're going to want to
insist that my death is bad for
me, we'd better be able to come
up with a date.
Well, maybe we can.
When would it be plausible to
claim my death is bad for me?
Well, not now.
My death can't be bad for me
now.
I'm not dead.
But it's not 100% clear that
the other alternative isn't
acceptable.
Why not say,
"My death is bad for me when
I'm dead"?
After all, when is a headache
bad for me?
When the headache is occurring.
Now, according to the
deprivation account,
the badness of death consists
in the fact that when you're
dead, you are deprived of the
goods of life.
So when is death bad for you?
During the time perhaps you're
being deprived of the goods of
life.
Well, when are you deprived of
the goods of life?
When you're dead.
When does the deprivation
actually occur?
When you're dead.
So perhaps we should just say,
"Well, you were right,
Epicurus," if this was
Epicurus' argument.
"You were right, Epicurus.
All facts have to be dated,
but we can date the
badness of death.
My death is bad for me during
the time I'm dead.
Because during that time,
I'm deprived of,
I'm not getting,
the good things in life that I
would be getting if only I were
still alive."
Well, that's a possible
response to the objection.
But of course,
it just immediately raises a
further objection.
How could it be that
death is bad for me then?
How could it be that death is
bad for me when I don't exist?
Surely, I have to exist in
order for something to be bad
for me.
Or, for that matter,
for something to be good for
me.
Don't you need to exist in
order for something to be good
or bad for you?
Well, this points our way to a
different possible
interpretation of Epicurus'
argument.
The argument would be (A)
something could be bad,
or for that matter,
good for you only if you exist;
(B) when you're dead you don't
exist;
so (C) death can't be bad for
you.
Put that up on the board.
(A) Something can be bad for
you only if you exist.
(B) When you're dead you don't
exist.
So, conclusion,
(C) death can't be bad for you.
Maybe that's the argument that
Epicurus had in mind.
Let's hear Epicurus'--the quote
from Epicurus again.
"So death, the most terrifying
of ills, is nothing to us,
since so long as we exist,
death is not with us;
but when death comes,
then we do not exist.
It does not then concern either
the living or the dead,
since for the former it is not,
and the latter are no more."
Again, the passage from
Epicurus isn't altogether clear,
but maybe he's got in mind
something like this argument.
Maybe Epicurus thinks look,
(A) something can be bad for
you only if you exist;
(B) when you're dead you don't
exist;
so (C) death can't be bad for
you.
Well, what should we say?
It's pretty clear that (B) is
true.
When you're dead you don't
exist.
And so the conclusion,
(C) death can't be bad for you,
looks like it's going to
follow, once we accept (A).
Call (A) the existence
requirement.
Something can be bad or,
for that matter,
good for you,
only if you exist.
That's the existence
requirement for bads and goods.
If we accept the existence
requirement, it looks as though
we have to accept the
conclusion, death can't be bad
for you.
What should we say?
Maybe what we should say is,
reject the existence
requirement.
In the ordinary case,
pains, being blind,
being crippled,
what have you,
losing your job--in the
ordinary case,
things are bad for you when you
exist.
In the ordinary case,
in order to receive bads,
you've got to exist.
But perhaps that's only the
ordinary case;
it's not all cases.
Perhaps we should say,
look, for certain kinds of bads
you don't need to even
exist in order for those
things to be bad for you.
What kind of bads could be like
that?
Well, of course,
deprivation bads would be
exactly like that.
To lack something,
you don't need to exist.
Indeed, the very fact that you
don't exist might provide the
very explanation as to why
you've got the deprivation,
why you've got the lack.
Not all lacks might be like
that, right?
Remember the television case.
You existed while you were
being deprived of the great
party.
You existed while you were
getting the mere $10 instead of
the $1,000.
So, sometimes deprivations
coincide with existence.
But the crucial point about
deprivations is you don't even
need to so much as exist in
order to be deprived of
something.
Nonexistence guarantees
that you're deprived of
something.
So perhaps we should just
reject the existence
requirement.
Perhaps we should say,
when we're talking about lacks,
when we're talking about
deprivations,
(A) is wrong.
We should reject the existence
requirement.
Something can be bad for you
even if you don't exist.
The existence requirement is
false.
Well, that would be a possible
way to respond to this second
possible interpretation of
Epicurus' argument.
It would be a way to retain the
thought that I take it we want
to have, that most of us share,
at least, that death is bad.
We'd be able to retain that
thought by rejecting the
existence requirement.
Well, easy to say that,
but there are some implications
of rejecting the existence
requirement that may be rather
hard to swallow.
Think about exactly what it's
saying.
It's saying something,
for example death,
nonexistence,
can be bad for somebody even
though they don't exist.
That's why my death can be bad
for me even though I won't
exist.
But if death can be bad for
somebody even though they don't
exist, then death could be bad
for somebody,
that is to say,
nonexistence could be bad for
somebody, who never
exists.
Take somebody who is a
possible person,
but never actually gets born.
It's sort of hard to think
about somebody like that.
So let's try to get at least a
little bit more concrete.
I need two volunteers.
I need a male volunteer from
the audience.
Good.
Okay, you'll be the male
volunteer.
And I need a female volunteer
from the audience.
Come on, it won't hurt.
I need a female volunteer.
Okay.
What I'd like you to do after
class is go have sex and have a
baby.
Okay.
Now, let me just suppose that
this isn't actually going to
happen.
Sorry.
Or sorry, I don't know.
Let's consider,
though, the possibility never
to be actualized,
the possibility that they would
have sex and have a baby.
His sperm joined with her egg,
form a fertilized egg.
The fertilized egg develops
into a fetus.
The fetus is eventually born.
It's the fetus that we got by
mixing egg 37 with sperm
4,000,309.
There's a person that
could have been born.
But let's suppose,
never does get born.
That particular person who
could have been born,
let's call Larry.
Okay.
Larry is a possible person.
It could happen,
but won't happen.
It could exist, but won't exist.
Now, how many of us feel sorry
for Larry?
Probably nobody.
After all, Larry never even
exists.
How can we feel sorry for Larry?
Now, that made perfect sense
when we accepted the existence
requirement, (A),
something can be bad for you
only if you exist.
Since Larry never exists,
nothing can be bad for Larry.
But once we give up on the
existence requirement,
once we say something can be
bad for you even if you never
exist,
then we no longer have any
grounds for withholding our
sympathy from Larry.
We can say, "Oh my gosh!
Think of all the goods in life
that Larry would have had,
if only he'd been born.
But he never is born,
so he's deprived of all those
goods."
And if death is bad for me,
by virtue of being deprived of
the goods of life,
then nonexistence is bad for
Larry, by virtue of his being
deprived of all the goods of
life.
I've got it bad.
I'm going to die.
Larry's got it worse.
We should really feel much
sorrier for Larry.
But I bet none of you feels
sorry for Larry,
this never-to-be-born-at-all
person.
Now, it's important in thinking
about this, that we not slip
back into some version of the
soul view,
especially some version of the
soul view where the souls are
prior existents.
You might imagine--there's a
scene in Homer,
I think, where some sort of
sacrifice is being made and all
the dead souls go hover around,
longing to be alive again,
to savor the food and taste and
smells of life,
right?
If you've got this picture of
the nonexistent,
merely potentially possible but
never-to-be born individuals as
somehow really already existing
in a kind of ghost-like state,
wishing they were born,
maybe you should feel sorry for
them.
But that's not what the story
is at all on the physicalist
picture that I'm assuming.
Nonexistent people don't have a
kind of spooky,
wish-I-were-alive ghost-like
existence.
They just don't exist,
full stop.
So once we keep that in mind
about Larry, it's very hard to
feel sorry for him.
Of course, look,
since I've been going on about
how he's deprived of all the
good things in life,
maybe some of you are feeling
sorry for Larry.
So it's worth getting clear
about just what it would mean to
take seriously the thought that
it's bad for merely potential
people never to be born.
How many merely potential
people are there?
I want you to get a sense of
just how many there are.
Not just Larry,
the unborn person that would
exist if we mixed whatever it
was, you know,
egg 37 and sperm 4,000,029,
whatever the number was.
Not just Larry,
who's a potential person who
never gets born,
that would have to be an object
of our sympathy,
there's a lot of merely
potential, never-to-be-born
people.
How many?
A lot.
Well, I once tried to calculate.
Well, as you'll see,
the calculation is utterly off
the back of the envelope,
sort of rough and completely
inadequate in ways that I'll
point out.
But at least it'll give you a
sense of just how many potential
people there are.
Let's start modestly and ask:
How many possible people could
we, the current generation,
produce?
Now as I say,
I made this calculation some
years ago.
It doesn't really matter how
inaccurate it's going to be.
As we'll see,
it's very rough,
but it makes the point.
How many people are there?
How many possible people,
rather, could there be?
Well, suppose there were 5
billion people.
Roughly half of them are men,
half of them are women.
What we want to know then is,
how many possible people could
the 2.5 billion men make
altogether with the 2.5 billion
women?
The crucial point in thinking
about this is to realize that
every time you combine a
different egg with a different
sperm,
you end up with a different
person, right?
If you combine an egg with a
different sperm,
you get a different genetic
code that develops into a
different person.
You combine that sperm with a
different egg,
you get a different person.
You know, if my parents had had
sex five minutes earlier or five
minutes later,
presumably some other sperm
would have joined with the egg.
That would have been not
me being born,
but some sibling being born
instead of me.
Change the egg,
change the sperm,
you get a different person.
So what we really want to know
is, how many sperm-egg
combinations are there with
roughly 5 billion people in the
world?
Well, let's see.
There's 2.5 billion women,
billion women.
How many eggs can a woman have?
Well, fertile periods,
round numbers,
it's not really going to
matter, precision,
roughly 30 years,
roughly 12 eggs a year.
So that's how many eggs.
Actually, I discovered some
time after having done this
calculation that the number of
possible eggs is far greater.
A woman actually ovulates and
gives off this many eggs roughly
during her fertile period.
But there's many,
many other cells,
I gather, that could have
developed into eggs.
So that's a much,
much larger number of potential
eggs.
But this will do.
30 years, 12 eggs a year.
How many men?
Roughly 2.5 billion men.
Each man has a much longer
period in which he's able to
produce sperm.
Let's just be round numbers
here, 50 years.
How many times a day can the
man have sex?
Well, certainly more than once,
but let's be modest here and
just say once a day.
So that's 365 times a day--a
year.
365 days a year.
365 days, I guess that should
be.
I wrote it too big.
I don't have space left for the
last number.
Each time the man ejaculates,
he gives off a lot of sperm.
How much sperm?
A lot.
As it happens,
I looked this up once.
Round numbers,
40 million sperm each time the
man ejaculates.
So this last number has got to
be times 40 million sperm.
Okay, so we took all the men
that exist now and all the women
that exist now and ask:
How many merely possible
people?
You know, most of these people
are never going to be born,
of course.
But we're talking about
possible people.
How many possible people are
there?
There's 2.5 billion times 30
times 12 times 2.5 billion times
50 times 365 times 40 million.
That equals--I'm going to round
here.
That equals approximately 1.5
million billion billion billion
people.
That's 1.5 x 10^(33).
That's how many possible people
we could have,
roughly speaking,
in the next generation,
of which obviously a miniscule
fraction are going to be born.
There's--If you're going to
feel sorry for Larry,
you've got to feel sorry for
every merely possible person.
Every person who could
have been born that never
gets born.
And there's 1.5 million billion
billion billion such people,
such possible people.
And of course,
the truth of the matter is,
we barely scratched the surface
here.
Because now think of all those
people and think about all the
possible children they
could have.
We got this number starting
with a mere 5 billion people.
Imagine the number we would get
if we then calculated how many
possible grandchildren we could
have.
I don't mean that we could
actually have all of those
people at the same time,
but for each one there is a
possible person that could have
existed.
You quickly end up with more
possible people than there are
particles in the known universe.
And that was just two
generations, right?
Three generations,
you're going to have more.
Four generations,
If we think about the number of
possible people,
people who could have existed
but will never exist,
the number just boggles the
mind.
And then, if we say we've
gotten rid of the existence
requirement and so things can be
bad for you even if you never
actually exist,
then we have to say of each and
every single one of those
billions upon billions upon
billions of possible people that
it's a tragedy that they never
get born,
because they're deprived of the
goods of life.
If we do away with the
existence requirement,
then the tragedy of the unborn
possible people is a moral
tragedy that mere--that just
staggers the mind.
The worst possible moral
horrors of human history don't
begin to even be in the same
ballpark as the moral horror of
the loss,
the deprivation for all of
these unborn possible people.
Now, I don't know about you,
when I think about it,
all I can say is it doesn't
strike me as being a moral
catastrophe.
I don't feel anguish and sorrow
and dismay at the loss,
at the lack,
at the deprivation for the
untold billion,
billion, billion,
billions.
But if we give up the existence
requirement and explain the
badness of my death via the
deprivation account,
we do have to say this is a
moral tragedy,
the fact that the billions upon
billions are never born.
Well, if we're not prepared to
say that's a moral tragedy,
well, we could avoid that by
going back to the existence
requirement.
But of course,
if we do go back to the
existence requirement,
then we're back with Epicurus'
argument.
Something can be bad for you
only if you exist.
When you're dead,
you don't exist.
So, (C), death can't be bad for
you.
And now we've really got
ourselves in a philosophical
pickle, don't we?
If I accept the existence
requirement, we've got an
argument that says death isn't
bad for me, which is really
rather surprising.
I can keep the claim that death
is bad for me by giving up the
existence requirement.
But if I give up the existence
requirement, I've got to say
it's a tragedy that Larry and
the untold billions,
billions, billions,
billions--it's a tragedy that
they're deprived of life as
well.
And that seems unacceptable.
What should we do?
What should we say?
The suggestion is that the key
here is to think about the claim
that I'm using deprived in two
different senses.
That when we worry about my
death, I'm losing
something--namely,
life--that I've had.
But in the case of Larry and
the untold billions,
they never had life.
And so they're not deprived of
it in that same sense.
I think it's a very promising
suggestion.
And indeed, I'm not 100% sure
I've got exactly where you want
to go with this in mind,
but I think there's a way of
taking that thought and sort of
carving a middle path.
The problem effectively was
this.
If we don't throw in any
existence requirement,
we have to feel sorry for the
unborn billion,
billion, billions.
That doesn't seem acceptable.
If we throw in the existence
requirement, (A),
something can be bad for you
only if you exist,
we end up saying death isn't
bad for me, because I'm not
existing when I'm dead.
But maybe there's a more modest
way of understanding the
existence requirement.
Or to put the point in slightly
different terms,
maybe we can distinguish
between two different versions
of the existence requirement,
a bolder and a more modest
version.
Let's see.
Here's the modest version.
Something can be bad for you
only if you exist at some time
or the other.
Bolder claim.
Something can be bad for you
only if you exist at the same
time as that thing.
All right.
These are two different ways of
understanding what the existence
requirement requires.
The modest version is called
modest because it's asking less.
It says something can be bad
for you only if you exist at
some time or the other.
The bold existence requirement
adds a stronger requirement.
It says something can be bad
for you only if you exist at the
very same time as the thing
that's supposed to be bad for
you.
There's got to be a kind of
simultaneity.
If something's bad for you,
you had better exist at the
very same time that that bad
thing is happening.
That's bolder than the modest
requirement.
The modest requirement doesn't
require that you exist that the
same time as the bad
thing.
It only requires that you exist
at some time or the
other.
One more minute,
we'll finish up.
Suppose we accept the bold
claim.
For something to be bad for
you, you have to exist at the
very same time as the bad thing.
Then death can't be bad for
you, because you don't exist at
the time of death.
Suppose, however,
that we accept the modest
requirement.
For something to be bad for
you, you have to exist at some
time or the other.
Well, since I do exist at some
time or the other--after all,
I exist right now--death can be
bad for me.
Admittedly, I won't exist when
I'm dead.
But that's okay.
The modest existence
requirement doesn't require that
I exist at the very same time as
the bad thing.
The bold one did,
but the modest one doesn't.
So the modest one allows us to
say that death is bad for me.
But notice, and this is the
crucial point,
it does not say that
nonexistence is bad for Larry,
because Larry never exists at
all.
And so he doesn't even satisfy
the modest existence
requirement.
In short, with no existence
requirement, we have to say the
unexistence of the billions and
billions is bad.
That seems unacceptable.
With the bold existence
requirement, we have to say
death isn't even bad for me.
That seems unacceptable.
But if, instead,
we accept the modest existence
requirement, we're able to say,
nonexistence is not bad
for Larry, but death is
bad for me.
And so that's the view that it
seems to me we should be looking
at.
Okay.